[Music]
it's the dawn of the 22nd century a time
of great hopes and expectations the
discovery of a new and inexhaustible
well of power known as zero-point energy
as revolutionized space travel men has
escaped the confines of Mother Earth and
gone on to colonize the solar system
what's up guys my name is Carsten and at
the commune manager here at zero-point
software Kim and Michael are currently
working their butts off getting the
first update of interested wins ready
for Steve so I decided to take matters
in my own hands
and tell you a bit about the game and
our plants so what is interstellar
Marines all about well if you ask you he
will definitely say something crazy like
interstellar Marines is an ambitious
indie game that makes it's meaningful
cooperative tactical role-playing with
relentless next generation first-person
simulation experienced inside a
believable science fiction narrative
about mankind's first contact with
another sentient species well if you ask
me interstellar Ares is basically the
ambitious dream of a crazy game
developer who played way too much
half-life system shock and Rainbow six
let's put up interstellar Marines and
take a look at some of the features
currently available right now we are
creating the multiplayer technology for
the game which will serve as the
development platform for the core co-op
experience that lies at the heart of
interstellar Marines the game currently
takes place at a high-tech military
training facility located deep beneath
the salt expanse of Groom Lake Nevada
here you will take on the role as an
elite soldier rigorously training for
hostile insertions outside our solar
system one of our goals is to make
interstellar Marines a highly dynamic
experience so our initial focus has been
to create a full dynamic light and sound
system used to simulate various combat
environments
we're sick and tired of floating cameras
and gun model stuck to the screen it's
another goal of ours is to create an
immersive first-person simulator that
makes you feel present and immersed in
the game right now our first-person
simulator has impressive features such
as and you can also open your helmet we
know it's not much but don't worry about
it with each update we'll expand the
game universe with more content story
and gameplay just like we know it for
Minecraft
you will play over 2 prototypes of
features in development that will enjoy
a few good lasts from box and occasional
game crashes but because we're
independent every decision we make is
for the love of the game which make
things very simple
the sooner you buy the lord of price and
once you purchase interstellar rates
you're all-in
I can't wait to make interstellar
Marines your home away from home here
are steam and I'm personally looking
forward to embracing your feedback and
suggestions to help make interesting
wings the best game possible kim has
promised me that with time during your
team will visit habitable planets all
over the solar system Force Base carries
and space stations and a hell a lot more
so I told him to put his money went by
this and show us a bit of a second
[Music]
[Music]